okay sweet last talk of the day let's do
it alright so hi my name is Nicole
Carlson pronouns she her hers that's my
email and Twitter handle today I'm going
to be talking to you about production
lysing and data science team so you may
be wondering what I mean by that when
you work as a single person on a project
you can organize things however you want
or not organize things once you start
working with more people though it's
likely you're going to need to add some
process to your workflow so this talk is
my best advice for adding that type of
process and I know thinking about
process is not everyone's favorite
activity but in the long term it will
make your team more productive and
efficient so here's a nice testimonial
about this from Morgan who's in the
front
she says I'm able to experiment a lot
more at work following our guidelines
because it just makes it easier to gets
easier to organize it all in my head and
get started on the actual functionality
so rather than finding it really
burdensome Morgan finds it really
helpful because she can spend her time
focusing on the data science work and
experimentation rather than figuring out
how to organize everything so a little
bit about me
I'm a former physicist so I came from
academia where you're obviously working
by yourself at my last company shift
gate I was the first data scientist
hired so I was embedded in a team of
software engineers for eight months
while I was the only data scientist we
slowly added more people and by the time
I left we had four people at my current
company shop earner I was the second
data scientist hired arguably the first
one who cared a lot about process and
over the last two and a half years we've
grown to a team of size 10 people so
this talk is about the things I picked
up watching these two teams grow so
here's an overview of what I'll talk
about today some prerequisites project
management everyone's favorite code
organization coding standards code
reviews the first piece of advice is you
should do code reviews model deployment
and documentation and I just want to
point out that this advice is meant to
be implemented by anybody on the team
whether you're an individual contributor
or a manager or a lead if you're excited
about one of these things you can get it
started with your team all right so
let's talk about prerequisites
the first one is pretty basic hire
people who want to work on a team I want
to interviewed someone who told me that
they wanted to be a black box they
wanted to sit in a room by themselves
all day somebody would pass in data and
they would pass out predictions
obviously we did not hire them because
they clearly did not want to work with
other people and that's fine there are
plenty of roles out there for people who
want to be the only data scientist at a
company so if you're hiring for a team
reject those people and hire people who
are excited about collaborating and
think it's valuable second piece of
advice hire people with strong opinions
is my coworker Greg he's really awesome
we disagree all the time and we have the
exact opposite opinions on a lot of
things but still super fun to work with
Greg we argue a lot but it forces me to
think a lot more about why I make the
choices I do and we respect each other a
lot so hire at least some people who are
opinionated but still willing to
compromise it's way better than having a
team full of apathetic people all right
project management so the most popular
form of project management that many
teams use from software engineering
would be agile and a lot of people hate
agile you can see this from the super
biased poll from our coworker
Michelangelo about how data scientists
feel about agile he's obviously not very
good at writing polls look at the two
middle ones they're obviously highly
biased opinions but you can see that the
majority of people chose the last one
the agile mindset is greater than agile
process and I believe that's true so as
you're thinking about what type of
project management workflow you need to
add to your team come up with a process
that works for your team so this is what
agile looks like for our team so we have
two-week sprints that's a ten at the end
behind the shadow we do stand-ups
everyday we do retros and we do sprint
planning so it's a modified version of
agile that works for us it helps us
figure out what each person is going to
work on how we're going to coordinate
work how we sign code reviews and how we
plan out larger projects so in
particular this is how our agile sprint
planning works so before the meeting
each person comes up with our own tasks
once we're in the meeting the group
discusses each task and
stomates how long we think it's gonna
take I know one reason a lot of data
scientists don't like agile is because
we have a lot of Rd and literature
review tests that are hard to point on
our team we just end up time boxing them
and kind of trying to give our best
guess of how long you think someone's
gonna need to take to learn about
something new and it's fine if our guess
is wrong but we have some estimate in
place any long-term project planning
happens outside of the meeting and
whoever's in charge is responsible for
getting the correct people together and
we assign code reviews after the meeting
so this is a process that works for us
it's slightly different from standard
agile so for example we don't have
project manager product managers writing
the stories each person writes their own
stories and in particular as you're
thinking about agile you should remove
parts that you don't need so for example
we used to use user stories so user
stories are meant to be something like
as a user I want to be able to log out
of the app for us we ended up with all
these ridiculous stories that were like
as a Hannah or a Nicole I want to be
able to do this as a data scientist I
want my code to work so we tried this
for a couple of months and then we were
like this doesn't make any sense we keep
ending up with these silly stories so
we're gonna stop doing that so that's
just an example of one part of agile we
threw up we don't look at burn down
charts we don't really care stories fall
out so we just have a system that works
for us you're also gonna need a place to
track your work someplace that you can
see what each person is working on what
you're going to work on next what's the
overall outline of your project so what
order should you do your tasks in what
are some potential future projects if
you somehow have free time which I'm
sure we all have and finally I think
this one is really important
what requests have you gotten from other
teams so having one place to track all
of that is really good it'll make them
feel heard and you can start to see
patterns and what people are asking you
for so some potential tools for this
JIRA Trello asana I've used them all
they all have various pros and cons a
different functionality most likely
you're gonna want to use something like
this because your team probably doesn't
want to spend their time building
project management software if you if
they do you probably all have a teen of
data scientists
so here's a testimonial from my director
of data science she says having a
project tracking system like JIRA has
been a lifesaver
I will regularly put our current sprint
side by side with our quarterly goals to
check in that were on the right track so
it can be super helpful for managers
having a spot where all this is together
and it's important for individual
contributors to so maybe if you're
waiting for a code review you can see
that somebody else is working on
something thing all right let's talk
about code organization so when I talk
about code organization I'm kind of
answering this question so what's next
after jeepers notebooks many of us start
our projects out working jeepers
notebooks or maybe when we start out as
data scientists we work exclusively and
JIRA notebooks and they're totally
awesome I really enjoy working with them
at some point though they can get kind
of unwieldy as you start adding in more
and more functionality it can be hard to
pass them around with your team to get
people to review them and if you're
working with software engineers they do
not want to learn how to install Jupiter
and open up a notebook so at some point
you're probably going to need to pull
your code out into proper Python
packages so my suggestion for that is to
choose a standard repo layout and use it
for all of your projects this is the
layout that my team uses so we have a
folder that's the project name in this
case Hermione's handbag we have a test
folder that mirrors the project folder
so if I need to know where a certain
function is being tested I know exactly
where to look and then we have a variety
of files that are the same from project
to project
so changelog docker files requirements
etc this is really useful because this
means if I'm reviewing somebody else's
code I know exactly how it's going to be
laid out I know if I want to find the
history of a project I just go to the
change log and it's gonna be formatted
the exact same way for everyone this is
really good for new people joining your
team too especially new data scientists
because they don't have to spend their
time coming up with what they think is
the best way to organize a Python
package they can just copy everything
from your other projects so there are
certain tools you can use to help with
this code generators so code generators
set up the scaffolding of a project for
you so you would give it for example
your repo
rebo name and it would set up the repo
folder the test folder the changelog the
readme all that good stuff so you don't
have to do it by hand and you know it's
gonna be uniform from project to project
you don't have to worry about somebody
forgetting things
cookie cutter is a pretty popular Python
one that I think a lot of data
scientists use my company uses yeoman
yeoman is nice because you can write
code generators in different languages
so you can be using the same tool as
other engineers so as you're organizing
all your code hopefully it's a nice neat
chunks of functionality but you may find
that there are various odds and ends
that don't fit so in those cases I
suggest you have some extra organization
common utilities repo my current company
it's called Hermione's handbag my last
company it was called sonic screwdriver
so what type of things are in this repo
so common sequel are you all running the
same types of queries over and over
again are you creating the same type of
tables put it in one place you're
probably all connecting to the same
databases so you don't need to be
rewriting that code in every repo put it
in the common utilities repo if there's
any common data transformations that you
know everyone needs to use with their
data put it in one place and a variety
of things maybe to help your coding so
logging helpers unit test helpers
visualization helpers etc I also really
like having this repo for new people
joining your team on our team we always
assign one ticket to the commute illa
T's repo for their first or second week
they can get something implemented right
away and they learn how our team process
processes work they don't have to spend
their time getting their whole big
project started something that may take
months they can just immediately see how
things work alright so your code it's
nicely organized now you have it in
these beautiful repos now it's time to
think about coding standards so what are
you putting in your repos some examples
of coding standards how long will your
lines be are you gonna stick to 80
characters like pep 8 says you should or
you gonna let people of infinite lines
what are you gonna do if you do set some
limit how are you going to continue long
lines do you care if people indent in
certain ways
how are you gonna rate your docstrings
do you want everyone to be doing the
same thing are you gonna use single or
double quotes when you have the option
and of course the classic tab versus
spaces so these are the types of things
I mean when I talk about coding
standards and I think it's really
important to develop some for your team
because it'll make it much easier for
you to read each other's code and to
review stuff so here are some tips for
developing your coding standards the
first is start from pep eighth pep
eighth is the coding standard set by the
Python Software Foundation I think many
people will already be familiar with it
coming in so you can start there and
look at what pieces make sense to your
team and what you want to use from Peppe
consult with software engineers at your
company if you happen to work with
python engineers ask them how they
format their code if you can use the
same standards as them it's gonna be way
easier when you're working together
because they'll be able to read your
code really easily so as you're looking
at all this stuff if there are cases
where all or most people agree make a
rule just say we're gonna do it this way
and everyone has to follow it if you
decide there are cases where there
doesn't need to be a rule then I suggest
that each person is consistent when they
write their own code if you're working
in a file continue all of your long
lines the same way do the same
indentation over and over again it'll be
way less confusing for other people to
read if you're consistent with yourself
if multiple people are working on a
project they should agree on a set of
standards for that repo so I mentioned
Greg earlier he and I collaborate a lot
so when we work in the same project he
gets his way on some things I get my way
on some things and we stick to them in
that project even though when we're
working in our own projects we kind of
do whatever we want if this seems like a
lot of work to try and enforce all this
you're in luck
there are tools to help one of the one
of which are linters so linters our
programs to automatically find code
violations so you run a linter over your
code it will tell you where your code is
breaking the standard you set so linters
look for programmatic and stylistic
errors programmatic is something like
your code tried to use an undefined
variable so for me that's often when I
have a typo stylistic would be things
like their lines are more than X
characters long
so the linter will go through and tell
you where all these areas are and then
you can go fix them yourself if that
seems like too much work you can use an
automated code formatter so with an
automated code formatter you run it over
your code it will find the violations
and then fix them itself letting a
computer change its code sounds like the
start of a robot uprising to me what a
lot of people are into this so a really
popular tool is black black is super
opinionated the authors a made a ton of
choices about how things should be
formatted
I think they chose wrong in a lot of
cases but a lot of people like this tool
Google has another one called Yap yet
another Python formatter this one is way
less opinionated but you need to
configure it to whatever choices your
team has set and I just want to point
out if you use one of these and you're
not everyone on your team uses them make
sure you're not just changing your
teammates code it's really disconcerting
to get a pull request or someone has
changed a bunch of files they weren't
even working in because their formatter
decided that the code should be
formatted differently here's a
testimonial from our co-worker Michael
he says my personal projects now follow
our team coding standards because it's
painful to look at things that aren't
formatted double-quotes burn my eyes now
he's correct double quotes are terrible
so having these standards in place isn't
a burden on people and in fact Michael
has found that he likes using it in his
own work so it's made him a better
programmer overall all right let's talk
about code reviews but first a
cautionary tale
so my coworker Michelangelo who had the
Turner poll or earlier really likes to
push directly to master when I joined
our company I was like you need to stop
doing it it's a terrible idea so one day
he very spitefully set up a one-line
pull request this one line pole request
was to add our new co-worker Hannah to
an authors file
Hannah reviewed this and said hey you
spelled my name wrong each tour Inc is
not H Torrance fine I then reviewed it
and said hey hey no Torrance comm is not
an email address you left out the ad
Gmail so this one line pull request had
two errors that required two reviewers
to find and this is why you should never
which to master so no matter how small
your changes or how perfect you think
your code is you're wrong it's not
there's gonna be some fun in it so set
up a pull request get someone to review
it there's like literally no downside to
it how many of you were taught how to
review code okay so very few people so
code review is something that's way less
common for data scientists to be taught
it's something that software engineers
are taught so that means that you need
to come up with a code review process
for your team because everyone's gonna
be coming from a different starting
place so the type of things you should
answer are how should an author prepare
a pull request so what things need to be
in place before they ask a reviewer to
look at their code so do all the unit
tests need to pass or are there a number
of linting errors that can make it
through all that type of stuff should be
laid out beforehand once the reviewer
has the code how should they review the
code are they looking for stylistic
errors are they only looking for
programmatic errors since we're data
scientists we often have a lot of math
in our code is the reviewer responsible
for checking that the math is correct or
do we just need to check that the code
does what it says it will do all this
stuff should be decided for your team's
code review process and what happens
when a pull request is approved does the
author merge it in does the reviewer
merge it in seems super weird but there
are places that do that when it's merged
in does it need to be deployed in some
way all this stuff should be codified so
there's no surprises about how people
should do code review and make sure you
teach new people how your team reviews
code since it's likely that everyone's
coming from a different starting place
think about how your process might be
different from other places so we had a
co-worker join our team he was super
surprised to learn that we would often
pull the code down locally and run the
unit tests it was really helpful for us
because we caught a lot of dependency
errors but he was super surprised
because his last team wasn't very
thorough about reviewing code so come up
with your process and teach it to new
people do pair code reviewing if you
need to walk them through what the
process is before they submit their
first pull request so they're not
surprised when they get a bunch of
comments back there are a number of
tools that can help with this
so the first one that we use is a pull
request checklist so we use these in
github so every time somebody opens up a
pull request they have to fill out this
checklist so these two make sure the
tests pass they need to make sure
they've described it and linked it to
JIRA if necessary they need to have
updated the change log and the version
all that type of stuff
so the author is responsible for
checking all these off before they ask
the reviewer to look at the code and
this has helped us catch a lot of errors
along the way by forcing people to go
through this process another thing that
can help our continuous integration
tools so this is a screenshot from
Jenkins which is a continuous
integration tool that my team uses every
time somebody sets up a pull request
these stages are run so first we run a
linter over the code this finds a bunch
of stylistic errors and it means that
the reviewer doesn't need to go through
and find all this stuff I've learned
that apparently not everyone else likes
alphabetizing things so getting a
computer to do it is super helpful if
it's a Python library we test that the
import works we run our unit tests and
we build the Python egg and wheel so
we're trying to make this as easy as
possible so that's the computer can
catch as many of the errors as possible
so your data scientists don't have to
spend as much time reviewing for this
stuff here's a testimonial from Nate I
set up continuous integration for my
personal project I set up a linter and
unit tests our PR process has ruined me
for the better so just like when Michael
Nate has found that he really likes our
process and he ended up using it in his
own work so people really like having
this stuff in place let's talk a little
bit about model deployment so you have
some nice model for your code for your
data and you're ready to start getting
predictions so the hard way of getting
getting predictions to people is this
somebody gives you some data
you take it you literally run to your
laptop open up Jupiter run it through
your model you get some results back and
then you run it back to whoever
requested the prediction this is often
how projects start out and it totally
makes sense in those beginning stages or
if you have a really small amount of
data at some point however you're
probably not going to want to do things
that way
having you as a human in the loop is
really inefficient and you're gonna be
blocking people when you're doing things
like eating and sleeping so what you
probably want to do is build a restful
api service this is basically like a
website people can go to there's an end
point where they can input their data
and then your model will make their
prediction and return it so my
suggestions for building your API is
choose one web framework for building
your api's and use the same one for all
of your projects if your software
engineers you probably need to learn the
pros and cons of a bunch of different
web frameworks and choose the best one
for your project but if you're a data
scientist you don't need to do all of
that you just need to find one that
works good enough for all of your
problems and use that for all of your
stuff again if you have Python software
engineers you can consult with them and
maybe they'll be able to help you choose
a good web framework some examples
bottle and flat Falcon are really
lightweight web frameworks Django is a
really heavyweight one you're only gonna
use Django if you know you need Django
and then the one I'm most familiar with
is flask it's kind of in between all
those and if you're unsure of what to
choose I suggest flask it's good enough
it's probably gonna be good enough for
your project alright once you have your
API is up and running you're gonna need
to support them in a variety of ways I
suggest that you spread out the board
the burden of support amongst your team
so things you're gonna need to do are
probably things like load testing
monitoring logging if your software
engineers you probably each need to
learn how all these different parts work
and be really good at it since your data
scientists though you don't need to
learn all of this instead each of you
can learn this stuff as it comes up and
then you can share that knowledge with
the team
so our co-workers Scott needed you load
testing for one of his api's he found a
tool called locust he was super excited
he got it's work he demoed it for us now
we all use locust none of us have done
any other research into load testing
because we don't care that much we're
data scientist we found something that
works and we're just gonna go for it
here's a testimonial from Kenna our
ability to deploy API serving model
results makes it much easier to get our
models
test it and in front of customers we
have many examples and extensive
documentation to make it easy to get
started with deploying a new model so
again we deploy all of our models the
same way so it makes it super easy you
can just copy what came before and in
fact our process is so straightforward
that one of our summer interns was able
to deploy a model because all he had to
do was look at another project and copy
everything over
Hana's quote also brings up
documentation that's my last point so
you should be documenting everything I
promise you nothing bad will happen if
you document everything it's totally
worth it so document everything your
workflow process did you come up with a
version that of agile that works for you
write it all down
are there meetings what does someone
need to do to prepare for those meetings
write it all down
you're awesome code review process that
you came up with whatever you came up
with should be documented that way
somebody can just go read about it
without having to talk to their team
mates whatever your deployment process
is you chose flasks you have some
monitoring whatever write it all down
it'll make things way easier for new
folks are there instructions and how
people should get access to things so
for example maybe you know that to get
access to a database they need to talk
to you the data engineering team to get
access to a username and password maybe
you need to get an API key by going to
the AWS console whatever write it all
down and I recommend that you're super
explicit in your instructions so often
software engineers will assume that
things in the command-line are really
obvious like everyone knows how to use
grep or whatever maybe your data
scientists don't they're coming from
different backgrounds and there's no
downside to being really explicit and
saying this is what you type in the
terminal to get the things you want
write it all down I also mentioned
writing it all down in exactly one place
so if you multiple systems for
documentation it's gonna be really hard
to keep them up to date you want your
stuff to be documented and discoverable
so I will go through a few more examples
so what things should you document
besides everything weird stuff in your
data this is an example of a product
table we have at my company you might
expect that the field called description
contains
product description but you would be
wrong it is instead in a field called
more underscore info that doesn't make
any sense it's super weird I happen to
know it because I work with this data
every day my colleagues do not know it
though because they're not working with
this data but it's all documented in our
wiki this way they can figure out all
the weird stuff without having to be
blocked by asking me this is also really
good for new people who join your team
you don't want them to spend like a
month or two months working on a project
only for them to present and then
somebody's saying like oh well that data
isn't valid like didn't you know about
it having it all written down means they
don't have to go through that all those
sweet coding standards you came up with
earlier write it all down your new
co-workers will be able to get started
much more quickly writing code and
they'll be able to write it in a way
where they won't get a billion comments
in their pull requests if you have the
coding students all written down
finally onboarding information every
time you on board somebody you're gonna
find out that some part of the process
has changed there's a new thing they get
need to get access to write it all down
having it in one place means you won't
forget it next time you may think that
you're gonna remember it but you're not
you're wrong so write it all down all
right here's a testimonial from our
co-worker Peter this is the first
company I've worked for where the wiki
pages were actually useful you'd go to
the instructions on how to set up AWS
access
follow the steps and it would actually
work so Peter joined pre recently and he
found that this was one of the best
onboarding experiences he'd had he was
able to start being productive really
early on because everything was
documented so some tools potential tools
for documentation I don't know why
they're all blue maybe a conspiracy who
knows so confluence is run by the same
company that owns JIRA it's a wiki it's
ok get book is having your documentation
and mark down and get repos I really
like it because then you have access to
like pull requests and branching and all
that nice stuff if you don't have access
to those you know just use Google Docs
use something have someplace to document
everything all right I hope you have
enjoyed this talk just a little bit of a
recap yes you need
some process in place for your team
whatever you choose being consistent
will take you a really long way document
everything it's like my favorite thing
to say and make sure you revisit your
choices periodically the process should
serve your team so that means that what
works when you're a teen a size three
may not work when you're a teen a size
ten so it should be constantly evolving
to meet the needs of your team
all right thanks questions any so I
would say - oh yeah so he was saying
that he's a team of four interns and
they're just getting started with adding
in process and stuff and I talked about
a lot of things so where would you start
as you're thinking about tackling all of
this uh honestly I think the best place
to start is whatever you're most
passionate about if it happens to be any
of these things right so I implemented a
lot of this stuff at shop runner but I
did it over like a year so when I first
joined I was like hey there's no Python
coding standards I'm gonna write one and
now everyone's gonna use them because I
care a lot about coding standards I
wanted to use JIRA so even though nobody
else on my team did I was like well I'm
gonna use JIRA just for myself and then
slowly other people started adopting it
so that's where I would start whatever
people want and maybe your interns are
super excited about cover view who knows
yeah
how did you go about essentially like
checking that what you've put into place
was actually like since you don't have
anyone else to consult with so I
basically first just started doing
whatever the software engineers were
doing and that's one reason why I'm
really thorough with code reviews now
it's because they would review my code
and they'd be super strict about
everything which is awesome but I just
copied what they did and then slowly
adapted it as we added more people we're
not that strict about it so we do have
some like older legacy packages that
don't meet our current standards but
basically we try when somebody is
working on one of those packages they
try to improve things or like make it
more consistent if they can but we know
that sometimes you're too busy to do
that so we understand that things are
going to drift and we'll try to catch
them up when we have time
which is never
so the question was about some way that
organized a lot of data input and output
not exactly sure what you mean by that
would you not want it to be like an I
guess I would probably just write a
bunch of scripts to handle that I don't
quite understand the use case maybe we
can talk after other questions
cool well thanks for coming you're free
now
[Applause]